well I think one of the great things
about I think one of the great things
about rock and roll and and and guitar
and in and the idea of America is is
that we're all we all have our own
unique voices and we mean I think that's
something that though we have very
distinctively since we've become a
country you know is that we can each one
of us our own opinions are just as
important as the next guy down the
street and that's the same as guitar you
know guitar is not like an instrument
that is stuck in a cannon you know or
stuck in like a particular form you know
you know blues is it continually add
like you know evolving thing you know
and blues and jazz and rock and country
and and to me I guess coming out of
playing violin where you had to play
those things perfectly you had to play
the notes were written on the page just
as they were written or you're playing a
wrong it was such a freeing thing so and
I've always really embraced the idea
that you know my own guitar playing is
very distinctively my own and and
whether it's good or not is beside the
point you know it's just it's my own
playing and it evolves in some ways it
gets better but it's always just mine
you know and I always thought that was
cool so I guess my advice in that way is
to never liked don't hold yourself to
whatever is being you know whatever is
on whatever's on the page you know and I
feel that way with whenever you're
somebody else's songs making your own by
playing it the way you would
I think it's not necessarily like the
right in the song part it's the it's the
willingness to like just survive you
know because it's like it's it's really
to me I don't know what I would do if I
wasn't doing this you know and if and I
feel that the you know it's it's
perseverance and then it's also
confidence you know and it's like there
are a few things in my life I have
confidence about like i have about
songwriting you know like and it doesn't
that doesn't mean that I that the song
is necessarily good it means that I
think it's good you know and I feel like
I'm you know and I'm willing to let the
songs that aren't very good go by the
wayside because i know i'll have a song
that I do feel that that kind of Eureka
feeling about and so it's you know and
and from what I've seen in 10 years of
playing music it's it's a complete
mystery to me what somebody else was
going to like you know what you know the
song that I think is just a great song
or friends of friends of mine who like
have like a great song and never get out
of their kind of bedroom with it that's
that is never makes sense to me you know
and you know it you know and and also
you know people who come out and they
are successful with a song that I think
what you know I don't understand why
there's no way to know those things so I
think that everybody starts out playing
music you know because they love it and
and you know if you're lucky you get the
chance to keep on doing it you know
because you love it but I think that
that's it's I have no idea why haha it's
a mystery